>> YES, EXACTLY.
>> I LIKE IT.
SEE IF YOU CAN DO BETTER THAN
JUAN.
JULIAN ASSANGE COULD SOON BE
EXTRADITED TO THE UNITED STATES.
DRAMATIC VIDEO SHOWING THE
BEARDED WIKILEAKS FOUNDER
SHOUTING AS HE WAS BEING HAULED
AWAY.
THE DOJ CHARGING HIM WITH
CONSPIRACY, CHELSEA MANNING HACK
INTO THE PENTAGON'S COMPUTERS.
THEY'RE VOWING TO FIGHT THE
EXTRA TR
EXTRADIR
EXTRADITION AND SAYING IT'S A
CRACKDOWN ON THE FREE PRESS.
>> ALL MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS IN
EUROPE AND ELSEWHERE AROUND THE
WORLD.
ANY JOURNALIST CAN BE EXTRADITED
FOR PROSECUTION IN THE UNITED
STATES FOR HAVING PUBLISHED
TRUTHFUL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
>> EDWARD SNOWDEN IS CALLING
ASSANGE ARREST, "A DARK MOMENT
FOR PRESS FREEDOM."
OTHER REACTION ALSO POURING IN.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE IN NATIONAL
SECURITY, IF YOU BELIEVE IN THE
SAFETY OF THE UNITED STATES,
HE'S A VILLAIN.
>> JULIAN AG I
>> JULIAN ASSI
>> JULIAN ASSANGE IS A HERO.
>> I DO NOT REGARD HIM AS A
HERO.
JULIAN ASSANGE HAS PUT AMERICAN
LIVES AT RISK.
>> I'M GLAD THAT THE WHEELS OF
JUSTICE ARE FINALLY TURNING WHEN
IT COMES TO MR. ASSANGE.
I'VE NEVER BEEN A FAN.
>> AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ALSO
ASKED ABOUT IT EARLIER.
>> I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
WIKILEAKS.
IT'S NOT MY THING.
I KNOW THERE IS SOMETHING HAVING
TO DO WITH JULIAN ASSANGE.
I'VE BEEN SEEING WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH ASSANGE.
AND THAT WILL BE A
DETERMINATION, I WOULD IMAGINE,
MOSTLY BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> ALL RIGHT, WELL, WE'LL GET TO
THAT IN A SECOND.
THE PEOPLE'S OPINIONS, GREG, OF
JULIAN ASSANGE HAVE REALLY
CHANGED OVER THE YEARS.
AT FIRST THE DEMOCRATS LOVED
HIM, THEN THEY HATED HIM.
WHERE DO THEY STAND NOW?
>> Greg: HERE'S THE DEAL.
I E-MAILED DANA AND OUR PRODUCER
MEGAN THIS MORNING.
I SAID, I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS
STORY BECAUSE I CAN'T EVEN
REMEMBER HOW I FEEL ABOUT JULIAN
ASSANGE.
BECAUSE WE -- WHEN "THE FIVE"
BEGAN, I GUESS -- GOING ON EIGHT
YEARS.
>> 2010, 2011.
>> Greg: I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW I
FEEL ABOUT ASSANGE AND I DON'T
THINK MOST OF AMERICA EVEN
REMEMBERS BECAUSE THE LAST THREE
TO FOUR YEARS HAS BEEN TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN.
EVERY IDEOLOGY, EVERY SIDE,
EVERY TEAM SPORT HAS BEEN
SOMEHOW MIXED UP AND CHANGED.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW I FEEL.
I WILL FIND AN ARGUMENT IN THIS.
PEOPLE UPSET ABOUT THIS ARREST
ARE SAYING THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
JOURNALISM, A DARK DAY ON
JOURNALISM.
IF THAT IS TRUE, YOU COULD NEVER
ARREST ANYBODY HACKING INTO YOUR
COMPUTER OR MAYBE EVEN BREAKING
INTO YOUR APARTMENT.
LET'S SAY MY ASSISTANT GOES INTO
MY COMPUTER AND TAKES ALL OF MY
E-MAILS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THERE'S
GOOD STUFF IN THERE OR BAD
STUFF, SHE IS STEALING MY
PROPERTY.
SHE SHIPS THAT OVER TO THE
"WASHINGTON POST" AND THEY HAVE
A STORY ABOUT ME RUNNING AN
AMAZING DRUG RING OUT OF MY
OFFICE -- NOT TRUE -- SHE HAD
BROKEN THE LAW.
BUT IF SOMEBODY IS TAKING
SOMETHING THAT BELONGS TO YOU,
IN THIS CASE THAT'S WHAT THE
CHARGE IS IS BREAKING INTO A
STATE DEPARTMENT COMPUTER AND
STEALING.
IF SOMEBODY COMES IN TAKING MY
E-MAILS, THAT IS THEFT.
CAN YOU CALL THEFT JOURNALISM?
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN.
THERE IS NO REPORTING IN THEFT.
RIGHT?
IT'S ONLY A STORY IF THEY FIND
SOMETHING IN YOUR E-MAILS.
BUT THAT'S NOT JOURNALISM.
THAT IS HACKING.
THAT'S MY THEORY.
>> THAT IS A GREAT THEORY.
ONE OF MANY GREAT THEORIES FROM
YOU, GREG.
DANA, THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
DIDN'T CHARGE ASSANGE WITH WHAT
HE IS NOW BEING CHARGED WITH.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WHY WAS IT NOT
ILLEGAL THEN, BUT NOW IT IS.
>> I THINK IT'S BECAUSE -- MY
OPINION ABOUT ASSANGE HAS NEVER
CHANGED.
I'M TEAM AMERICA.
WHAT HE -- HE'S NOT EVEN
AMERICAN.
HOW DOES HE GET FIRST AMENDMENT
PROTECTION FOR JOURNALISM.
>> Greg: NOW WE REMEMBER THE
SHOWS WE DID.
>> Dana: BUT I WAS RIGHT.
IT IS VERY INTERESTING.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, THEY'RE
STYMIED.
THERE WERE ACTUAL INTELLIGENCE
HARMS THAT WERE DONE, DIPLOMATIC
HARMS THAT RESULTED FROM THIS.
THEN YOU HAVE BRADLEY MANNING'S
TRANSFORMATION.
OBAMA PARDONED HER AT THE END.
THEN THESE PEOPLE TAKE ON THESE
MYTHICAL -- LIKE THEY'RE HEROS.
ONE'S A HERO AND ONE'S A HEROI
IN, NOW.
THEY COULDN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CHARGE HIM WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO
GET JOURNALISTIC PROTECTION.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
BE LIKE, LOOK IT UP, WE FIGURED
IT OUT.
THROUGH ADDITIONAL
INVESTIGATION, MAYBE WE'LL FIND
THIS OUT, THEY WERE THE ONES TO
SAY THIS IS NOT A FIRST
AMENDMENT CLAIM, THIS WAS A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
THEY WANT ALL OF OUR INFORMATION
TO BE OPEN AND FREE TO
EVERYBODY, EXCEPT THEY HOWL
ABOUT INTERNET COMPANIES AND
PRIVACY.
>> IT IS BIZARRE.
JUAN, LOOK GREAT TODAY AFTER A
BIG BIRTHDAY NIGHT OUT, I'M
SURE.
>> Juan: OH, YEAH, THAT WAS ME.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE LEFT IS
TRYING TO LINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
WITH JULIAN ASSANGE NOW, PULLING
ALL THESE TAPES, I GUESS, FROM
THE CAMPAIGN WHEN THE PRESIDENT
WAS SAYING WIKILEAKS, I CAN'T
WAIT TO READ WHAT THEY SAID.
I GUESS THAT'S THE NEW
COLLUSION, PERHAPS, IS THAT IT?
>> Juan: I THINK HE WAS
ENCOURAGING THEM.
TODAY, HE SAYS, WIKILEAKS, I
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT WIKILEAKS.
IT'S SO OBVIOUSLY WRONG-HEADED
AND HE'S JUST TRYING TO AVOID
ANY CONNECTION.
LET'S LEAVE THAT ALONE.
THAT'S POLITICS.
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
STORY BECAUSE IT'S EVIDENCE THAT
THE -- FIRST, THE ECUADORIANS
THREW HIM OUT.
>> Dana: HE WAS ALSO THREATENING
THEIR GOVERNMENT.
>> Juan: CLEARLY THE FIRST STEP
IS THAT THEY HAD BEEN GRANTING
HIM ASYLUM BY HOLDING HIM IN
THAT EMBASSY.
ONCE HE'S OUT, THEN HE'S SUBJECT
TO POSSIBLE EXTRADITION.
NOW, THE U.S. CHARGE IS VERY
CAREFUL.
IT DOESN'T GET INTO THE ARGUMENT
THAT GREG AND DANA HAVE BEEN
GOING THROUGH ABOUT JOURNALISM,
NOT JOURNALISM.
IT SAYS YOU WERE A
CO-CONSPIRATOR HELPING CHELSEA
MANNING HACK INTO OUR DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT COMPUTERS.
THAT'S CLEARLY ILLEGAL.
THAT'S WHY HE CAN BE EXTRADITED
AND LIKELY TO LOSE THAT CASE, IN
MY OPINION.
WHEN YOU ASK ME, THOUGH, YOU
KNOW, I GOT HURT BY WIKILEAKS
BECAUSE I LOST MY CELL PHONE AND
I WAS AWAKENED IN LAS VEGAS
AFTER IT WAS HACKED AND THEY HAD
MY CELL PHONE.
IT'S JUST VERY UNPLEASANT.
>> I GOT TO USE THAT EXCUSE
ONCE, TOO.
>> Greg: YOU WERE ANSWERING THE
PHONE ON AIR.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> Juan: PEOPLE GOT A HUGE KICK
OUT OF YOU ANSWERING MY PHONE.
AFTERWARDS PEOPLE WERE STILL
CALLING NUMBERS, SO I GOT RID OF
IT AND THEY'D SAY, CAN I TALK TO
GREG.
WHAT ABOUT ME!
[ LAUGHTER ]
AM I CHOPPED LIVER HERE?
SERIOUS NEWS ORGANIZATIONS, YOU
CAN WALK IN AND SAY, HEY, JUAN,
HERE'S THE PENTAGON PAPERS.
I'LL SAY, WELL, LET ME SEE IT.
IT'S NOT ME TELLING YOU HERE'S
HOW TO BREAK THE LAW.
>> Greg: THE ALLEGATION WAS HE
WAS TRYING TO CRACK THE
PASSWORDS IN ORDER TO INFILTRATE
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SYSTEM.
AMAZE
AMAING HOW HE WAS ABLE TO STAY
IN THE EMBASSY FOR SEVEN YEARS.
THERE MUST HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
BEHIND THE SCENES DEALINGS WHEN
THE ECUADORIANS, THE BRITISH,
AND THE U.S.
>> NO LONGER.
LEGALLY THINK OF IT AS A
BRILLIANT STRATEGY,  FRANKLY,
THAT THE JUST D.O.J. HAS
UNDERGONE AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
THEIR BURDEN OF PROOF IS SO LOW,
IT'S SO CLEAR, IT'S SO SIMPLE.
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH WHAT WAS STOLEN OR
PUBLISHED OR DONE, IT WAS, YOU
BROKE INTO THE HOUSE.
THERE'S NO DEFENSE BEYOND THAT.
THE UK-U.S. EXTRADITION TREATY,
RIGHT NOW AT THIS POINT THE NEXT
STEP AFTER THIS BAIL THING WHICH
WE KNOW HE MIGHT FACE A YEAR IN
JAIL IN THE UK, THE UK COURT
WILL REVIEW THE CHARGING
DOCUMENT.
IF THERE IS THE REQUISITE
SPECIFICITY, THEN THEY EXTRADITE
HIM HERE.
AS WE KNOW, HE FACES UP TO FIVE
YEARS IN PRISON.
TO ME, THAT IS INTERESTING.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE THE
SHOW.
THE SEVEN YEARS OF HIS
SELF-IMPOSED COMPILE AND THE
WRETCHED CREATURE WE SAW BEING
BROUGHT OUT OF THE EMBASSY
TODAY, HE WAS IN A WORSE HELL
AND WORSE PRISON ANTICIPATING
ALL OF THIS AND WORRYING ABOUT
IT AND FREAKING OUT THAN --
>> -- LIKE PAMELA ANDERSON.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS?
>> IF THERE IS, IT'S USUALLY
FIVE YEARS.
BECAUSE HE WAS GRANTED ASYLUM BY
ECUADOR, IT TOLLS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
THERE IS NO WAY THEY UNDERWENT
ALL THIS WITHOUT HAVING THEM
KNOW THEY CAN RELY ON THAT TO
PULL IT, WHICH MEANS TO PAUSE
IT.
I THINK --
>> ON THE LEFT PEOPLE SAY THAT
HE'S A HERO BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
IT TURNED OUT THAT HE REVEALED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, IN FACT, MONITORING
OR SURVEILLING AMERICAN CITIZENS
AND WE, AS AMERICANS, HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW IS THE ARGUMENT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THIS.
THIS ABOUT A GUY PARTICIPATING
IN AN ILLEGAL BREACH OF AMERICAN
SECURITY.